The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I've
been getting to play
with this robot for
a few years now--
three years of my life
basically devoted to that robot.
It was one of the most exciting,
technically challenging,
exhausting, stressful, but
ultimately fulfilling things
I've ever done.
We got to basically take this
robot, make it drive a car,
get out of the car--
that was tough-- open the door,
turn valves, pick up a drill,
cut a hole out of the wall.
Notice there's no
safety hardness.
It's battery autonomous.
It has a walk over
some rough terrain,
climbed some stairs at the end.
It had to do this in
front of an audience.
Basically, we got two tries.
And if your robot
breaks, it breaks, right?
And there was a $2
million prize at the end.
We wanted to do it not
for the $2 million prize,
but for the technical challenge.
And myself and a group
of students, just
like I said, absolutely
devoted our lives to this.
We spent all of our
waking hours on this.
We worked incredibly,
incredibly hard.
So just to give you a
little bit of context,
DARPA, our national
defense funding agency,
has gotten excited
about the idea
of these grant challenges,
which get people
to work really, really hard.
The self-driving cars
were the first one.
MIT had a very successful
team in the Urban Challenge
led by John.
And then it's unquestionably
had transition impact
into the world via Google,
Uber, Apple, and John
will tell you all about it.
I think in 2012, DARPA was
scratching their heads, saying,
people haven't
worked hard enough.
And what's the new
challenge going to be?
And right around
that time, there
was a disaster that maybe
helped focus their attention
towards disaster response.
So ultimately, it
was October 2012
that everything started
with this kickoff
for the DARPA
Robotics Challenge.
The official challenge was
cast in the light of disaster
response using the scenario
of the nuclear disaster
as a backdrop.
But I think really
their goal was
to evaluate and advance
the state of the art
in mobile manipulation.
So if I'm the funding
agency, what I think
is that you see
hardware coming out
of industry that is fantastic.
So Boston Dynamics was
building these walking robots
and the like.
This one is the one
we've been playing,
Atlas, built by Boston
Dynamics, which is now Google.
AUDIENCE: Alphabet.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Alphabet, yeah.
And then I think from
the research labs,
we've been seeing really
sophisticated algorithms
coming out but on
relatively modest hardware.
And I think it was time
for a mash up, right?
So they were very
interesting in the way
they set up the competition.
It wasn't about making it a
completely autonomous robot.
There was there was a twist.
You could have a human
operator, but they
wanted to encourage autonomy.
So what they did is they
had a degraded network
link between the human and
the robot and some reward
for going a little bit
faster than the other guy.
So the idea would be that
if you had to stop and work
over the degraded
network link and control
every joint of your
robot, then you're
going to be slower than
the guy whose robot is
making the decisions by itself.
That didn't play out
as much as we expected,
but that was the setup.
That set up a
spectrum where people
could do full
teleoperation, meaning
joystick control of each of
the joints if they wanted to.
And maybe the goal is to
have complete autonomy,
and you can pick your
place on the spectrum.
So MIT, possibly to a fault,
aimed for the full autonomy
side.
The idea was, let's just get
a few clicks of information
from the human.
Let the human solve the
really, really hard problems
that he could
solve efficiently--
object recognition.
Scene understanding-- we
don't have to do that,
but a few clicks from the
human can communicate that.
But let the robot do
all of the dynamics
and control and
planning side of things.
So those few clicks should see
nearly autonomous algorithms
for perception,
planning, and control.
OK.
So technically, I don't intend
to go into too many details,
but I would love to answer
questions if you guys ask.
And we can talk as much
as we want about it.
But the overarching
theme to our approach
when we're controlling,
perceiving, everything
is to formulate everything
as an optimization problem.
So even the simplest
example in robotics
is the inverse
kinematics problem
where you're just
trying to decide
if I want to put my hand
in some particular place.
I have to figure out if I have
a goal in the world coordinates.
I have to figure out what
the joint coordinates should
be to make that happen.
So we have joint positions
in some vector q,
and we just say, I'd like
to be as close as possible.
I have some comfortable
position for my robot.
We formulate the problem
as an optimization-- say,
I'd like to be as close
to comfortable as possible
in some simple cost function.
And then I'm going to start
putting in constraints,
like my hand is in the
desired configuration.
But we have very
advanced constraints.
So especially for the
balancing humanoid,
we can say, for
instance, that the center
mass has to be inside
the support polygon.
We can say, we're about
to manipulate something.
So I'd like the thing
I'm going to manipulate
to be in the cone of visibility
of my vision sensors.
I'd like my hand to approach.
It doesn't matter where it
approaches along the table,
maybe, but the palm should
be orthogonal to the table
and should approach like this.
And we put in more
and more sophisticated
collision avoidance
type constraints
and everything like this, and
the optimization framework
as is general and can accept
those type of constraints.
And then we can solve
them extremely efficiently
with highly
optimized algorithms.
So for instance, that
helped us with what
I like to call the big
robot little car problem.
So we have a very big robot.
It's a 400 pound, six
foot something machine.
And they asked us to
drive a very little car
to the point where the
robot physically does not
fit behind the steering
wheel-- impossible.
It just doesn't kinematically.
Torso's too big, steering
wheel's right there, no chance.
So you have to drive
from the passenger seat.
You have to put your
foot over the console.
You have to drive like this,
and then our only option
was to get out of
the passenger side.
So that was a hard
problem kinematically,
but we have this rich
library of optimizations.
We can drag it around.
We can explore different
kinematic configurations
of the robot.
But we also use the same
language of optimization
and constraints, and then we
put in the dynamics of the robot
as another constraint.
And we can start doing
efficient dynamic motion
planning with the same tools.
So for instance, if we wanted
Atlas to suddenly start
jumping off cinder blocks or
running, we did a lot of work
in that regard to
make our optimization
algorithms efficient
enough to scale
to very complex
motions that could
be planned on the fly
at interactive rates.
So one of the things you
might be familiar with--
Honda ASIMO is one of
the famous robots that
walks around like this, and
it's a beautiful machine.
They are extremely good at
real time planning using
limiting assumptions
of keeping your center
mass at a constant height
and things like this.
And one of the
questions we asked is,
can we take some of
the insights that
have worked so well
on those robots
and generalize them to
more general dynamic tasks?
And one of the big ideas I want
to try to communicate quickly
is that even though our robot
is extremely complicated,
there's sort of a low
dimensional problem sitting
inside the big high
dimensional problem.
So if I start worrying about
every joint angle in my hand
while I'm thinking about
walking, I'm dead, right?
So actually, when you're
thinking about walking, even
doing gymnastics or
something like this,
I think the fundamental
representation
is the dynamics of your
center of mass, your angular
momentum, some bulk
dynamics of your robot,
and the contact forces you're
exerting on the world, which
are also constrained.
And in this sort of
six dimensional--
12 dimensional if you
have velocities-- space
with these relatively
limited constraints,
you can actually do
very efficient planning
and then map that in a second
pass back to the full figure
out what my pinky's going to do.
So we do that.
We spent a lot of
time doing that,
and we can now plan motions
for complicated humanoids that
were far beyond our ability
to do it a few years ago.
This was a major effort for us.
My kids and I were
watching American Ninja
Warrior at the time, so we did
all the Ninja Warrior tasks.
So there were some
algorithmic ideas
that were required for that.
It was also just a software
engineering exercise
to build a dynamics engine that
provided analytical gradients,
exposed all the
sparsity in the problem,
and wrote custom solvers
and things like that
to make that work.
It's not just about humanoids.
We spent a day after we got
Atlas doing those things
to show that we could make
a quadruped run around using
the same exact algorithms.
It took literally
less than a day
to make all these examples work.
There's another
level of optimization
that's kicking around in here.
So the humanoid, in some
sense when it's moving around,
is a fairly continuous
dynamical system.
There's punctuations when
your foot hits the ground
or something like
this, so you think
of that as sort of a smooth
optimization problem.
There's also a discrete
optimization problem
sitting in there,
too, even for walking.
So if you think
about it, the methods
I just talked about--
we're really talking about,
OK, I move like this.
I would prefer to move
something like this,
but there's a
continuum of solutions
I could possibly take.
For walking, there's also
this problem of just saying,
am I going to move my right foot
first or my left foot first?
Am I going to step on cinder
block one or cinder block two?
There really is a
discrete problem
which gives a
combinatorial problem
if you have to make
long-term decisions on that.
And one of the things
we've tried to do well
is be very explicit about
modeling the discrete aspects
and the continuous
aspects of the problem
individually and using the
right solvers that could think
about both of those together.
So here's an example of how
we do interactive footstep
planning with the robot.
If it's standing in front of
some perceived cinder blocks,
for instance, the human can
quickly label discrete regions
just by moving a mouse around.
The regions that come out are
actually fit by an algorithm.
They look small, because
they're trying to figure out
if the center of the foot
was inside that region,
the whole foot
would fit on that.
And they're also thinking
about balance constraints
and other things like that.
But now we have discrete
regions to possibly step in.
We have a combinatorial
problem and the smooth problem
of moving my center
of mass and the like,
and we have very good
new solvers to do that.
And seeded inside
that, I just want
to communicate that there's all
these little technical nuggets.
We had to find a new way to
make really fast approximations
of big convex regions
of free space.
So we have optimizations
that just figured out--
the problem of
finding the biggest
polygon that fits inside all
those obstacles is NP hard.
We're not going to solve that.
But it turns out finding
a pretty good polygon can
be done extremely fast now.
And the particular
way we did it scales
to very high dimensions
and complicated obstacles
to the point where we could
do it on raw sensor data,
and that was an enabling
technology for us.
So our robot now, when
it's making plans--
so the one on the left is
just walking towards the goal.
The one on the right, we
removed a cinder block.
And normally, a robot would
kind of get confused and stuck,
because it's just thinking
about this local plan,
local plan, local plan.
It wouldn't be able to
stop and go completely
in the other direction.
But now, since we have this
higher level combinatorial
planning on top, we can make
these big, long-term decision
making tasks at
interactive rates.
Also, the robot was too
big to walk through a door,
so we had to walk
sideways through a door.
And that was sort of
a standing challenge.
The guy who started the program
putting footsteps down by hand
said, whatever I do
in footstep planning,
I will never lay down footsteps
to walk through a door again.
That was the challenge.
We did a lot of work on
the balancing control
for the robot, so it's
a force controlled robot
using hydraulic
actuators everywhere.
Again, I won't go
into the details,
but we thought a lot about
the dynamics of the robot.
How do you cast that as
an efficient optimization
that we can solve on the fly?
And we were solving an
optimization at a kilohertz
to balance the robot.
So you put it all together.
And as a basic competency,
how well does our robot
walk around and balance?
Here's one of the
examples at a normal speed
from the challenge.
So the robot just puts
its footsteps down ahead.
The operator is mostly
just watching and giving
high level directions.
I want to go over here, and the
robot's doing its own thing.
Now, all the other
teams I know about
were putting down the footsteps
by hand on the obstacles.
I don't know if someone else
was doing it autonomously.
We chose to do it autonomously.
We were a little bit
faster because of it,
but I don't know
if it was enabling.
But very proud of our
walking, even though it's
still conservative.
This is lousy
compared to a human.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the obstacles are
modeled by the robot's vision,
or do you actually preset them?
RUSS TEDRAKE: So we knew they
were going to be cinder blocks.
We didn't know the orientation
or positions of them,
so we had a cinder block
fitting algorithm that
would run on the
fly, snap things
into place with the cameras--
actually, laser scanner.
And then we walk up stairs.
Little things-- if you
care about walking,
the heels are
hanging off the back.
There's special
algorithms in there
to balance on partial foot
contact and things like that.
And that made the difference.
We could go up there
efficiently, robustly.
So I would say though,
for conservative walking,
it really works well.
We could plant these
things on the fly.
And we also had
this user interface
that if the foot step planner
ever did something stupid,
the human could just drag a foot
around, add a new constraint
to the solver.
It would continue to solve
with a new constraint
and adjust its solutions.
We could do more dynamic plans.
We could have it run
everything like that.
We actually never
tried this on the robot
before the
competition, because we
were terrified of
breaking the robot,
and we couldn't
accept the downtime.
But now that the
competition's over,
this is exactly
what we're trying.
But the optimizations are slower
and didn't always succeed.
So in the real scenario, we were
putting some more constraints
on and doing much more
conservative gaits.
The balance control I'd
say worked extremely well.
So the hardest task was this
getting out of the car task.
We worked like crazy.
We didn't work on
it until the end.
I thought DARPA was going
to scratch it, honestly.
But in the last month, it became
clear that we had to do it.
And then we spent a
lot of effort on it.
And we put the car in
every possible situation.
This was on cinder blocks.
It's way high.
It has to step down almost
beyond its reachability
in the leg.
This thing was just super solid.
So Andres and Lucas
were the main designers
of this algorithm.
I'd say it's superhuman
in this regard, right?
A human would not
do that, of course,
but standing on one
foot while someone's
jumping on the car like this--
it really works well.
In fact, the hardest part
of that for the algorithm
was the fact that it's trying
to find out where the ground is,
and the camera's
going like this.
So that was the reason
it had this long pause
before it went down.
But there was one time
that it didn't work well,
and it's hard for
me to watch this.
But it turns out on the first--
you saw that little kick?
This was horrible.
I'll tell you exactly
what happened,
but I think it really
exposed the limitation
of the state of the art.
So what happened in that
particular situation was
the robot was almost
autonomous in some ways,
and we basically tried
to have the human
have to do almost nothing.
And in the end, we got
the humans checklist
down to about five items,
which was probably a mistake,
because we screwed
up on the checklist.
So one of the five
items was to--
we have one set of programs
that are running when
the robot's driving the car.
And then all the
human had to do was
turn off the driving controller
and turn on the balancing
controller.
But it was exciting and the
first day of the competition.
And we turned on the balancing
controller, forgot to turn off
the driving controller.
So the ankle was still
trying to drive the car.
Even that, the controller
was robust enough.
So I really think there's
this fundamental thing
that if you're close
to your nominal plan,
things were very robust.
But what happened is the ankle
is still driving the car.
I think we could balance
with the ankle doing
the wrong thing, except the
ankle did the wrong thing
just enough that the tailbone
hit the seat of the car.
That was no longer something
we could handle, right?
So there was no contact
sensor in the butt.
That meant the dynamics
model was very wrong.
The state estimator
got very confused.
The foot came off the ground,
and the state estimator
had an assumption that the
feet should be on the ground.
That's how it knew where
it was in the world.
And basically, the
controller was hosed, right?
And that was the only time we
could have done that badly--
the vibrations and everything.
I had emails from people
of all walks of life
telling me what they thought
was wrong with the brain
of the robot from
shaking like that.
But that was a bad thing.
So you know I think
fundamentally,
if we're thinking about plans--
and that's what
we know how to do
at scale for high dimensional
systems is single solutions--
then we're close to the plan.
Things are good.
When we're far from the
plan, we're not very good.
And a change in the
contact situation--
even if it's in a Cartesian
space very close--
change in the contact situation
is a big change to the plan.
There's lots of
ways to address it.
We're doing all of them now.
It's all fundamentally
about robustness.
But ironically, the
car was the only time
we could have done
that badly, right?
So every other place, we
worked out all these situations
where, OK, the robot's walking,
and then something bad happens
and someone lances
you or something.
We had recovery.
And then even if it
tried to take a step--
even if that failed, it
would go into a gentle mode
where it would
protect its hands,
because we were afraid
of breaking the hands.
It would fall very
generally to the ground.
All that was good.
We turned it off exactly
once in the competition.
We turned it off when
we were in the car,
because we can't take a step to
recover when you're in the car
and you're the same
size of the car.
And we didn't even want
to protect our hands,
because once we got our hand
stuck on the steering wheel.
So anyways, that
was the only thing
we could have sort of shaken
ourselves silly and fallen.
And what happened?
We fell down with
our 400 pound robot.
We broke the arm--
the right arm.
Sadly, all of our
practices ever were
doing all the
tasks right handed,
but we got to show off a
different form of robustness.
So actually, because we had so
much autonomy in the system,
we flipped a bit
and said, let's use
the left arm for everything.
Which is more than just map the
joint coordinates over here.
It meant you had to
walk up to the door
on the other side of the door.
The implications
back up quite a bit.
After having our arm
just completely hosed,
we were able to go through and
do all the rest of the tasks
except for the drill,
which required two hands.
We couldn't do that one.
We had to pick up the
drill and turn it on.
So we ended the
day in second place
with a different
display of robustness.
AUDIENCE: That's still
pretty damn good.
RUSS TEDRAKE: We were
happy, but not as happy
as if we had not fallen.
OK.
So I think walking around,
balancing-- we're pretty good,
but there's a limitation.
I really do think everybody has
that limitation to some extent.
The manipulation
capabilities of the robot
were pretty limited, just
because we didn't need
to do it for the challenge.
The manipulation
requirements were minimal.
You had to open doors.
Picking up a drill was the
most complicated thing.
We actually had a lot of
really nice robotic hands
to play with, but they all broke
when you started really running
them through these hard tests.
So we ended up with these
sort of lobster claw
kind of grippers, because
they didn't break.
And they were robust,
and they worked well.
But it limited what we
could do in manipulation.
Again, the planning
worked very well.
We could pick up
a board and even
plan to make sure that the
board now didn't intersect
with other boards in the world.
And we have really good
planning capabilities,
and those worked at interactive
rates-- the kinematic plans.
But the grasping was open loop,
so there's really no feedback.
So there's current sensing
just to not overheat the hands.
But basically, you
do a lot of thinking
to figure out how to get
your hand near the board.
And then you kind of close
your eyes and go like this,
and hope it lands in the hand.
And most of the time, it does.
Every once in
awhile, it doesn't.
We experimented with
every touch sensor
we could get our hands on.
That wasn't meant to be a pun.
And we tried cameras
and everything,
but they were all just too
fragile and difficult to use
for the competition.
We're doing a lot of work
now doing optimization
for grasping, but I'll
skip over that for time.
So the other piece
was, how does the human
come into the perception
side of the story?
So one of these tasks
was moving debris
out from in front of a door.
This is what it looked like
in the original version
of the competition-- the trials.
The robot would come up
and throw these boards out
of the way, and you see the
human operators over there
with her big
console of displays.
This is what the laser
in the robot's head sees.
We have a spinning laser.
We also have stereo vision.
But the laser
reconstruction of this
gives you a mess of points.
If you asked a vision
algorithm-- some of you
are vision experts
I'm sure in the room.
If you asked a vision
algorithm to figure out
what's going on in
that mess of points,
it's an extremely hard problem.
But we have a human in the loop.
So the idea is that one
or two clicks from a human
can turn that from an
intractable problem
to a pretty simple problem.
Just say, there's
a two by four here.
And then now a local search
can do sort of RANSAC type
local optimizations to
find the best fit to a two
by four to that local group of
points, and that works well.
And so the robot didn't have
to think about the messy point
clouds when it's
doing its planning.
It could think
about the simplified
geometry from the CAD models.
And most of the planning
was just on the CAD models.
So this is what it looks
like to drive the robot.
So you click somewhere
saying there's a valve,
then the perception
algorithm finds a valve.
Then the robot starts going.
It actually shows you a ghost
of what it's about to do.
And then if you're
happy with it,
and if all things are
going well, you just watch.
But if it looks like it's
about to do something stupid,
you can come in, stop,
interact, change the plans,
and let it do its thing.
It's kind of fun to watch the
robot view of the world, right?
So this is what the robot sees.
It throws down its footsteps.
It's deciding how to
walk up to that valve.
Again, when the
right arm was broken,
this was one of
our practice runs.
The right arm was
broken, it had a valve.
We had to bit flip, and
now it had to walk over
to the other side of the valve.
And there's a lot
of things going on.
A lot of pieces had to work well
together to make all this work.
One of the questions that
I'll get before you ask it.
If you've written it
down, OK, that's fine.
Why were the robots so slow?
Why were they standing still?
A lot of people out there
waiting for the human, maybe,
but for us it wasn't.
It wasn't the planning time.
The planning algorithms
were super fast.
Most of the time, we were
waiting for sensor data.
And that meant there
was two things.
There was waiting for the
laser to spin completely around
and also just being
conservative-- wanting
to get that laser data
while the robot was stopped.
And then there was getting
the laser data back
to the computer that
had the fast planning
algorithms in back.
So if there was a
network blackout,
we had to wait a
little bit, and that
meant we were standing still.
But we've actually done
a lot of work in lab
to show that we don't
have to stand still.
This is now the robot
walking with its laser
blindfolded and using
only stereo vision
using one of the capabilities
that came out of John's lab
and others to do stereo fusion.
The laser gives very
accurate points,
but it gives them
slowly at a low rate.
And you have to wait
for it to spin around.
The camera is very dense, very
high rate, but very noisy.
And John and others have
developed these new algorithms
that can do real time
filtering of that noisy data,
and we demonstrated that
they were good enough
to do walking on.
And so we put all the
pieces together-- real time
footstep planning, real
time balancing, real time
perception-- and we were able to
show we can walk continuously.
This will be the future.
So we had to do networking.
We optimized network systems.
We had to build servers, unit
test logistics, politics.
It was exhausting.
I think it was overall
incredibly good
experience-- a huge success.
I think the robots
can move faster
with only small changes
mostly on the perception side.
The walking was sufficient.
We can definitely do better.
The manipulation was very basic.
I think we need to
do better there,
but we didn't have
to for those tasks.
The robustness
dominated everything.
So I'll just end
and take questions,
but I'll show this sort
of fun, again, robot view.
This is the robot's God's
eye view of the world
while it's doing
all these tasks.
You can sort of see what the
robot labels with the geometry
and what it's
leading its points.
And it's just kind of fun to
have on in the background,
and then I'll take
any questions.
[APPLAUSE]